there's been a lot of discussion about
william bowery and his identity
because it's not a real person
yeah remember those rumors that taylor
swift's boyfriend
joe alwyn co-wrote two songs on her
latest album folklore under a fake name
while taylor she just confirmed it so
william bowery is joe as we know
and joe's joe plays piano beautifully
and
he's always just playing and making
things up and kind of creating things
the 30 year old singer revealed the
mystery for us in her disney plus
concert special folklore the long pond
studio sessions
which premiered on wednesday i'm so
excited
the couple first teamed up for her song
betty and that chorus
well taylor said joe wrote it in the
garden would you trust
me if i told you it was just a summer
thing
i'm only 17. i don't
[Music]
i just heard joe singing the entire
fully formed chorus of betty
from another room yeah and i just was
like
hello it was a step that we would never
have taken because
why would we have ever written a song
this was the first time we had a
conversation
where i came in and i was like hey this
could be really weird
and we could hate this could we just
because
we're in quarantine and there's nothing
else going on can we just try to see
what it's like if we write this song
together
so clearly joe was down and taylor said
he inspired the idea to tell the story
of betty
from a male perspective he was singing
the chorus of it and i thought it
sounded really good
from a man's voice from a masculine
perspective
and i really like that it seems to be an
apology we decided to make it
from a teenage boy's perspective
apologizing after he loses the love of
his life because he's
been foolish the 29 year old actor also
contributed on his girls collab
alongside
bonavere on the song exile before
[Music]
exile was crazy because joe had written
that entire piano part that dun dun
the way that the whole first first verse
is wow and so
i was entranced
and asked if um we could
keep writing that one and pretty it was
pretty obvious that it should be a duet
because he's got such a low voice and it
sounded really good
sung down there in that register fans
first suspected that
joe was bowery before folklore even came
out
when taylor announced the surprise album
and thanked collaborators bonavere
aaron desner jack antonoff and william
bowery
i love getting to do this and i i live
to write songs that's what i live for
naturally swifties did what swifties do
and went into
full on sherlock holmes mode bowery was
the only collaborator who wasn't tagged
in the grammy winner's post
and after no registered songwriters or
producers could be found with that name
they dug even deeper and remember that
in the early days of taylor and joe's
romance
they were snapped outside the bowery
hotel in nyc
then they found out that joe is the
great grandson of english composer and
musician
william alwyn william alwyn plus bowery
hotel
equals william bowery damn swifties are
good
i don't even i can't on wednesday taylor
appeared on good morning america to
discuss the concert film
but she played coy about the big reveal
we finally
learned the identity of your mystery
collaborator william bowery
you know one thing about this special is
that
we got to delve into how we made the
album stories
behind these lyrics and it was really
great to get to
go behind the scenes and tell people but
you got to watch it
i knew you weren't going to spoil that
right there and t swift whose newest
album is nominated for five grammys this
year
opened up about re-recording her old
music after her original masters were
sold in 2019
taylor opened up about the experience of
singing her songs
all over again and revealed which one
was the most fun to redo
so far the of the ones i've recorded i
think it's been the most fun doing love
story because
the older music my voice was so teenaged
and i
sometimes when i hear my older music and
my older young teenage voice it makes me
feel like
i'm a different singer now and so it's
been the most fun to go back and
re-record ones that i feel like i could
actually
possibly improve upon
the song
you